la vie c'est d'être au lit avec toi tout le
reste n'attend que bien toi oui j'ai l'
intention de t'aimer jusqu'à ma mort moi premier
conseiller mon dos contre le mur mec les
problèmes du Mali sont des problèmes sérieux je
vais le mettre en place 625 kilos on est probablement
en regardant à 1 million je sais pourquoi en dehors
de ça tu veux la belle bague tu veux savoir
combien ça vaut j'ai toujours pensé qu'un
diplôme en droit était une licence pour voler tu
n'avais pas vraiment capitalisé sur je suis vraiment
inquiet peut être que ça va aller  si
vous poursuivez cette route et que vous vous y êtes
engagé, vous finirez par prendre des
décisions morales qui vous prendront complètement
par surprise, vous devriez faire attention à ce que
vous souhaitez,
vous ne l'obtiendrez peut-être pas, conseiller,
nous avons un problème dans l'expédition, c'est
parti
J'ai reçu un appel de nos partenaires commerciaux
ces gens sont sortis de 20 millions ils pensent que
nous sommes tous impliqués ne savent-ils pas juste
vous conseiller
vous ils ne croient pas aux coïncidences
ils ont entendu parler de lui ils ne
vous ont jamais vu  en difficulté quand la
hache arrive  Bien que la porte que nous avons déjà
commencée
pensez-vous que je devrais faire comment les amis
ici nous en avons tous fini ici
il est trop tard je peux disparaître en un
clin d'œil pouvez-vous le massacre à venir
c'est probablement au-delà de notre imagination que vous
êtes le monde que vous avez créé  et quand
vous cesserez d'exister, ce monde que vous
avez créé cessera également d'exister